l'état considéré qu'il n'était pas face
en fait à son peuple
il a considéré qu'il était face à des
opposants politiques
les religieux n'ont été traités comme
des opposants politiques
il n'y a pas eu des excuses publiques de
la part de l'état
m
par le premier frein évidemment ces dix
gp la police qui enquête sur la police
c'est un frein le deuxième frein
évidemment ça reste mes procureur public
parce que les procureurs de la
république je le rappelle sont rattachés
au pouvoir exécutif
kindred forme évidemment à envisager de
l'igpn
vous avez beaucoup plaintes qui ont été
classées sans suite parce que
rappelez-vous surtout en 2019
on disait que on n'avait pas retrouvé le
cireur parce que j'ai vidéo sur place de
la république où nous suivons la place
du châtelet ne fonctionnait pas donc qui
empruntent d'indépendance et
d'impartialité du gp qui dépendent du
rein directeur général groupe nationaux
qui lui une avance d'une dépend du midi
de l'intérieur sur les violences
policières
c'est simplement le tireur qui met en
cause déjà mais le donneur d'ordre et
les balles du tireur vu la moye
abandonné par sa hiérarchie drac la
justice en fait met en cause les vrais
donneurs d'ordre
la premier source your money dizaines de
courriers de plaintes à l'encontre du
trapèze idéalement ils appliquent bien
la politique du gouvernement et la
politique du gouvernement à l'encontre
des idées jaune c'était de réprimer ce
mouvement social le plus rapidement et
peu importe le moyen employé
le fait que l'état reconnaisse en fait
qu'il a fauté dans l'exercice de sa
mission de maintien de l'ordre public et
ça en fait la plupart des personnes qui
en étaient blessés ou mutilés le
réclament mais le pire c'est quand même
pas d' excuses lui aucune excuse
publique
certes l'état on va être condamné
financièrement ça y'a pas de problème
mais ça va être un bout de papier qui
permet alors j'ai pas que ça permet de
réparer complètement quoi à partir du
moment où vous avez l'état en tout cas
le gouvernement qui a reconnu en fait
qu'il a failli dans sa mission
voilà je pense qu'une réparation
psychologique peut commencer
entre novembre
2018 et novembre 2019
vous avez vu 300 arrêtés préfectoraux
qui ont été émis par des préfets pour
interdire des manifestations j'ai des
jaunes 300 c'est énorme
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui les gens qui
manifestent sont traités par l'état
comme des opposants politiques etc c'est
un glissement super bien je crois qu'on
est en train de vivre actuellement
[Musique]